forget all of that yes and I'm glad I'm
glad what you said your brother you get
me because I feel like every time I get
my point across people say I'm wrong but
I feel like the past the past is very
important so I'm trying to say some
things build your character some things
are part of you yeah it does I'm sorry
because if I don't wanna do I'm sorry
you've done you've done so now what I've
got a pickup baggage I've got to deal
with luggage I'm sorry so yeah man for
me I don't judge anyone I've done a
video myself
as a man's you love the hoes appreciate
the hoes nothing's wrong with them
for me now but can you work from
Marriage
there are two types of holes though
no no
there are some people who have been
through traumas and sex is there is
their way of coping so that's how they
become a hole they're becoming a whole
wait for mental traumas all right I'd
like to I'd like to just add one thing
what I'm hearing what I'm hearing here
right here wait wait
is an excuse no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no okay okay
who's who's out who's ad-libbing there
are some people that if you if you read
documents and all that they get raped
and all that they get say grape
okay
they get graped and because I'm saying
grape I'm forgiving but but remember
so then they kind of they feel depressed
and they go through a lot of things and
they don't they don't just they don't
respect themselves and that's when that
comes out is this the exception or is it
the rule no it's not it's not an except
now there's another type of hole which
they they they know what they're doing
they're sleeping around and they're
happy just to live but here's but here's
the problem with even the first show the
world doesn't owe you understand it
[Applause]
there's some people that go through that
and don't make those choices and so if
you if you choose to make those choices
like it's still the choice you made and
you can't whine about it
but pearly do you know what that's what
people underestimate but some people we
all we all have different Hearts we all
grow up differently we all go through
different experiences
but as as human beings as people
you can be understanding and treat them
with respect and politely but that
doesn't mean that other men have to date
and about some people actually heal some
people when they get loving kids
I have to be honest I have to be honest
right before I started the show
um I really thought healing meant
something else I really thought when
women like healed they went to therapy
but I just found healing is like another
word for just sleeping around
you come back in now and then they write
in their journals
guys guys guys stop stop interrupting me
stop stop they do some meditating and
now
they're healed no yes no I don't think
really what's like I think healing works
with actually
self-reflecting challenging yourself and
think okay how can I how can okay I've
done this this wasn't very nice and you
self-reflect and you figure out how
you're gonna heal how you're gonna get
through how you're gonna to treat a
situation differently I do agree with
you there's there's learning from
experience right
um but it's like how many times you got
to have the same experience before you
learn you know what I mean it's like one
two three twenty Thirty
I've seen I don't know why but always
stranger girls come and talk to me and
they tell me their whole lives and and
what I find sad is and that's why I say
like it's so important for us as humans
to be understanding because
some people mentally they're not
beautiful
I think that we should be less
understanding yes no I think I think I
think okay I think it's good I think
it's good to be understanding when it
comes to Mental Health
I think that okay nowadays everybody's
got a mental health everybody everyone's
got it
everyone's got yeah
remember when oh you know what my least
favorite word is now trauma trauma
trauma used to be about war not your
ex-boyfriend cheating on you three times
but now now this is my trauma I've gone
through trauma because my ex-boyfriend
like no that's supposed to be cool
because she took me about three times so
you're the kids
[Laughter]
are you saying in most cases when people
talk about relationship trauma they're
only talking specifically about the
cheating
giving
no pause no pause giving giving
but this is this is
giving when you say giving okay one man
up what about woman up yeah
it's like okay when you have trouble man
it's not even from relationships who's
more who's who's more traditional men
make more than women at large for a
lifetime men make more than women women
way more than men and they have higher
body counts than men so who needs to
manage have higher body constant men yes
sorry sorry guys guys guys one person at
the time there's a lot of overtoking
support because at the end of the day so
one person at a time let the moderator
pick the person who's talking thank you
one out of three men are either virgins
or haven't had sex in the past year have
one out of three women are they virgins
or haven't had sex in the past year
I couldn't it's a bit both like
um
I need to just say this like we you've
heard stories where men have gloated
about oh absolutely 250 women you will
never hear a woman say that unless she's
from only fans you know I mean yeah
no I'm sorry I've just never experienced
that conversation because we're not
gonna brag about that stuff no and one
person but it goes back to a small
percentage of men are having a lot of
sex that's what he was saying earlier so
a small percentage of men they're the
biggest horror you know they're man
[__] right right and so you're right
there are a small percentage of men that
are having more sex than women but by
and large women are having more sex than
men I don't know I don't think that's
scary I'm scared
nobody's the contraceptive pills I'm
telling you it's all different products
you know why because what she's saying I
think is that the chances of a woman to
get more men and hide in it is measured
in a man getting a woman and you never
say something please go on sorry sorry
I'll say after no because think about it
every woman here yeah think about think
about your DMs yeah think about now
think about your DMs yeah yeah now think
about
if you really wanted to you could have
at least well good looking women anyway
not saying no I'm not you know what I
mean you could you could have at least
actually I'd like to kind of correct
just one thing one thing I'm gonna
correct then you can finish
um an average woman gets more matches on
dating apps than a top one percent okay
this is what I'm just about to say if
you look at your DMs you know for a fact
if you run if you just rang someone or
just said yeah come true how many
geezers could you have as many as you
wanted exactly that's what I'm saying so
realistically women probably do have the
more sex or we could do if we wanted to
yeah but
what she's trying to say is that you
don't actually know how many women they
say out loud
that's what I'm saying I'm disagreeing
with what she said because it's the
truth because realistically it's done
it's the women it is is literally when
you think about your DMs because it's
this crazy place
if you walked into a bar and you just
you stood in the bar and you said I'll
[__] every Geezer here
imagine how many would do imagine how
many how many members they've done that
on YouTube before so yeah so they have
like a girl go up to guys and a guy go
up to girls and it's like over half the
guys are like okay because she was a
cute girl and they had a hot guy go up
to girls and it was like 99 of them said
no yeah exactly
that's what that was what went
so doesn't that show the statistics of
women trying to just keep themselves to
themselves like because okay all women
I'll be like oh they don't want extra
body count no I think I think it shows
what's easier to get like it's easier
for women to get sex than men yeah so
it's like men a man has to have
something for you to be interested in
him like you're a pretty girl so it's
like you're gonna want him to have a
good job right definitely you want them
to be taller than you I've been I've
been very spoiled right yeah
you wanna you wanna so you are picky
earlier yeah okay
you want him to be taller than
do you find attractive usually would you
say I like men that are taller than me I
like to look up how tall are you so out
of out of ten men you maybe maybe you'll
find so if you're like the stats you'll
find too attractive so out of the 15
you're gonna find two out of the ten
that are over six foot attractive yeah
and let's say let's say one of them is
in your income category that you look
for and one isn't so you're looking for
one percent of men and most women most
women are looking most women two baby
bums most women are looking for one
percent and you want them to have no
kids right I want to be the first and
that's what I'm saying it's all a
possibility like I said I did use some
date a very rich guy and he made me
become very high
um when we start dating I was like oh my
God how am I gonna get to right get this
level how am I no that's the thing
statistics statistically you probably
won't replace him statistically you
probably want girls because he was rich
I'm just saying my DM's be possible yeah
yeah but yeah
[Applause]
like crazy messages but you you know
come on DM they don't count it doesn't
count but obviously out of those DMS one
of them did I mean I mean
that's my point that's what every girl
thinks every girl's walking through life
thinking they're gonna win the lottery
and date this top one percent money has
to be over six foot he has to make over
70k he has to be attractive he has to be
a champion but see this this is this is
but this is here here wait this is the
problem that sounds nice it's it sounds
nice and like and it's possible but it's
not probable it's probably not going to
happen so so I'll tell you I'll tell you
another stat okay so big banks are
investing in things like cat food wine
because 50 of women are projected to be
single childless over 30. so that means
all the girls in this room half of us
will never have kids okay half of us
will never get married so if you say oh
just manifest it believe it sounds nice
and it's also like if you don't get
married by 35 your odds of getting
married and having a long stable
relationship ever it's very it's very
low it's very low I actually a lot of
women yeah
[Music]
actually I'm gonna uh
I want to read
when a single woman reaches the age of
30 the statistical probability of her
sex successfully finding a long-term
relationship and having just one child
Falls below 50 it then declines rapidly
by 3.5 percent to five percent each year
this is based on the average fertility
rates in developed countries of course
but it's also based on the average
amount of time it would take a single 30
year old woman to find a good mate and
progress the relationship to the point
of pregnancy
um a little messed up is what you
consider the average age of first child
is 29 for women it varies very slightly
by country and most women start taking
the idea of a family seriously in their
late 20s and 30s
um
and let's talk about ivf2 61
um the the failure rates of IVF is 61.1
percent in women under 34. so out of 100
women that go and get IVF 61 fail um and
women that are between the ages of 35 to
38 is 73.7
86.2 percent in women ages 39 to 42 and
94 in women over the ages of 43 have
that's the IVF failure rate wow isn't it
now that there's more female binge
drinkers than male for the first time
ever yeah that's true that's crazy yeah
that's crazy which part there's more
female yeah there's more you can grab
yeah it was like it was something that
came out earlier this year that there
are now more female bench drinkers than
males and it's the first time in history
this has happened wow that's crazy
green so um okay there's there's smoking
more so so men smoke boy and woman drink
more yeah but that's the first time I'm
in history that women are drinking more
but why is that
because we're an evolving race because
women are becoming men
that men are becoming women
I'm going to read one more thing to you
guys according to the average span of
committed relationships of committed
dating relationships the average them
and the average interval of time women
take between relate relationships an
average woman has a maximum of guess how
many serious relationships three how
many four three plus two five five yeah
um
guys wait let me finish a maximum of
five serious relationships five swings
at a bat before her chance of starting a
family drops to zero so that means if
you've had five boyfriends your chance
of a family is dropped to zero wait wait
wait please can you explain that again
according to the average span of
committed dating relationships average
and the average interval of time women
take between relationships the average
woman has a maximum of five serious
relationships five swings at the bat
before her chances of starting a family
drops to zero
um they need to change locations
that's depressing according to numbers
like so they think how many people wait
what if they what if the new generation
what if these people are just willing to
love easily more easily but this is but
this is like we always do a roundabout
way to make the numbers not sound like
what they are but this is what any
numbers when people started creating
numbers okay numbers wait numbers were
only numbers when people started
creating numbers
how did you counter Rock like how did
how many rocks before they were okay
this isn't this doesn't make any sense
um
they do surveys it's self-reported in
different countries around the world and
they all have similar numbers so so they
they start to have a similar conclusion
and a similar Trend so when we when we
tell women oh it's gonna be okay it's
like my DMs are full this this for a lot
of women for a lot of women it's not
going to be okay and out of women that
don't have kids eighty percent of them
wish they had them it's gonna be okay
at the end of the day that's what I'm
saying sometimes these conversations
could also go to the other side of this
one room wait explain that so what do
you think I think that these sort of
conversations we have they can sometimes
be very strategic and stats have stated
and these people yeah but there's a
whole group community of people who
don't do surveys and just live their
life and love people and talk to people
they're not real and they don't give
their reports back yes okay okay
some people you're right some people
don't take surveys but if we're doing
surveys in different places and they're
all concluding the same thing it's like
if you don't want to believe numbers you
don't have to you can just live in the
in the land of feelings as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible